hello welcome to ed talks with khan
academy we are excited to have you here
as we talk to people who are influential
in the education space today we're
talking to olive chewie who has a book
coming out that we're looking forward to
talking to you about learning
before we get started i want to remind
you first that khan academy is a
non-profit and we rely on donations from
folks like you to help us do the work
that we're doing so if you have the
ability to
whatever amount works for you to help us
continue on our mission we really
appreciate that support
uh we also during covet 19 i've had some
companies that have really stepped up
and want to express our appreciation for
them those include bank of america at t
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors thank you
also if you want to catch up on some of
the video chats that you have missed and
maybe you're on the go and want to catch
a podcast you can catch them and the
homeroom with sal the podcast wherever
you get your podcasts and find those and
enjoy in your in your spare time or on
the elliptical as i do
and so today as i said we have an author
with us who has today released in the
u.s learn like a pro
science-based tools to become better at
anything
olive chewy is joining us today and we
are looking forward to talking about
learning welcome olaf thank you
it is great to have you here
so
first as we get started i like to just
find out from people how they got to be
interested in learning uh you know most
of us were students at some point and
struggled or at different points with
learning and how that came in but not
everyone takes that and says i'm going
to become an expert at this thing so how
did you take that journey
so we need to go back to junior high
school when i was a quite average
student in most respects and i noticed
that around that time that's when we
started getting grades on the tests that
we were doing and i i found out that i
was sort of quite average and other
students were doing better and i
struggled to
reach the top of the the grading score
the grading scale
and so i
i assumed that in order to get good
results in school you had to be very
smart and i had a world view that some
people were born extremely intelligent
and they did well and the rest didn't
stand a chance to do well in school but
then i also discovered that those in
class who got the good grades they had
other study habits than i had they had
other study methods and so i thought
what happened what would happen if i
adapted the way i studied so i started
reading about how to learn
and that eventually helped me improve my
results in school i eventually graduated
with the highest grade point average in
high school
i was admitted to the university of
oxford
and
and so i really benefited in my life
from learning about learning and
once i was done with my education i
wanted to help others learn how to learn
so
that's great
so what was something that back in those
days that you actually tried and was you
found to be helpful for you
so
um
back in those days typically when i was
reading i thought that the the number of
times you read through some the more you
read something the better so if i read
through a chapter three times for
example that would be great and that
would be three times as
good as if i only read through it once
what i discovered however was that even
after reading it three times i didn't
necessarily remember it so much and if i
slow down and stop to think about what i
was reading
checking if i had understood it i
retained much more
and so that was just one small discovery
and i made tons of these discoveries i
also tried a lot of things that didn't
work very well for example i listened to
audiobooks at night during sleep and
thought that might be a very efficient
way to learn but uh
i woke up very grumpy and tired so uh
but i did a lot of this experimenting
back and forth and
eventually found some really good ways
to learn
yeah
i had a friend who used to read her
notes and then i similarly played them
when she slept and she realized it was
actually not the playing them when she
slept but it was like reading through
and saying the notes in her own words
again that was actually helping her
learn and she didn't need to play them
while she was sleeping to get the
benefit of that
definitely
exactly
um i also had that reading piece was my
experience as well like you feel like if
i just highlight the right things and
then keep re-reading them that that must
get it into my brain and turns out
that's not how it works so much
what many people will do is that they
paraphrase for example so they have
something written in the book and then
they just copy that over to their own
notes and it can take a lot of time and
it takes a lot of effort but you might
transfer something over onto another
paper but it doesn't transfer into your
long-term memory
yeah absolutely
so
before we get more into that let me also
ask so i know you did this language
learning experiment in buenos aires
argentina tell us a little bit about
that
yeah so i've always been interested in
languages and foreign cultures and i've
been wanting to learn spanish for quite
a long time
actually but learning a language is such
a massive big task and i never really
had the time to
to focus on it and and really pursue it
um but then i had some time right before
the pandemic and i thought now i've
spent so much time learning about
learning so
i
created a challenge for myself where i
where i tried to see if i could become
fluent in spanish in just one month by
applying the best techniques for
learning that i had come across and by
focusing on it fully for one month and i
did it and one week ago i released a
documentary about it that's on youtube
um in case you want to see that's where
i started
excellent
that is that is great that you got to do
it right before the pandemic hit reality
to stay home so good timing yeah that
was actually excellent uh timing just
right before
everything closed down
excellent that is great well i as you
said i i caught it on youtube as i was
looking at you know kind of doing some
research for this this
show and was
interested to see what you had done
so what prompted you to write this book
so uh this book is uh is is uh a joint
project between myself and uh dr barbara
oakley who's also written several other
books on learning and we connected a few
years ago i we both published our first
book about learning in 2014
and it both books did fairly well
um
and and then a few years ago we we we
connected we found
we
sort of found
found a lot of common ground
and
we decided to write the next book on on
how to learn taking into account
you know everything we have learned
since the last book that we wrote about
learning and we also felt that people
now are so
busy there's so much to do there's so
many things to learn that there was a
need for a very concise to the point
book that explains what you should do
but but also but also why but in a very
concise manner so we challenged
ourselves to write a very
handy uh
book
and and that book was published today
great great so
viewers there's a reminder you can put
questions in the chat here so let's dive
into some of the the pieces about
learning so i'm one of the big um
pieces about learning is how do we move
things from kind of that working memory
where it's active and we're you know
able to manipulate things into our
long-term memory where we can access it
later and think about where things are
how what are some good ways to be able
to do that to get that
information into long-term memory
so there are several of course but what
psychology has found is that one of the
most robust and uh best techniques is
retrieval practice
and it's funny because when we're
learning we often want to place things
into long-term memory but it turns out
the best way to get things into
long-term memory is to take it out
retrieve it out as many times
as possible
so retrieval practices any it can be can
be really anything where you try to um
try to remember what you just read it
can be closing a book after you read a
chapter and and then trying to recall
what you just read it can be writing
down
um
what you've just learned
it can be studying with flashcards for
example you see you're learning foreign
vocabulary you see the the word in in
english on one page one side and then
you try to remember what the foreign
language uh
version was that's on the other side
and you can also discuss with others but
then without
too much too much too many
too much help just trying to recall from
your own memory
yeah it's
um it always strikes me that when you're
trying to remember something what you're
doing is you're pulling it out of memory
so that's what you should practice doing
is pulling things out to be able to
access them that always
makes it it's almost as if you know if
someone if you were storing something
into the forest
and it can be easy to forget where it's
stored but if you make a path and you
walk that path you know back and forth
uh enough times that vegetation will
break down and then you'll have a very
solid path that's that makes it easy for
you to access
you know whatever you've stored
there and and um
and so yeah it's really about using what
you learned not just passively absorbing
or uh but but actually actively using it
and bringing it out of long-term memory
that makes sense
so
how do you i know that um
dr oakley does a lot of neuroscience
work and there's a lot of in the book
neuroscience basis for a lot of these
things what are some things that that
you found the that kind of explanation
for
that you found was it really helpful in
understanding why maybe something works
for learning is there an example of
where there's a good biological basis
for the recommendation that
that you're making
yes i'd say oh i mean overall and we put
put great emphasis on that in the book
also showing why certain techniques work
and what i find is that when you
understand a little bit of the
neuroscience it becomes much easier to
use good techniques because you get a
much richer understanding of the
technique so you can apply them a little
bit better in the right situations
uh etc and so one of the things that i
found very very helpful um
uh
from neuroscience which which barb has
been you know teaching for a few years
is this difference between the
between the task positive and the task
negative networks
which we call the diffused and the
focused mode of the brain and basically
what
what that means is that the brain has
two different modes of thinking and
learning it has a mode which is very
focused
which is when you're working actively to
to solve a problem or to think about
something but then it also has a mode
which which works when you are relaxing
or when you are not focusing intently on
something which we call the diffuse mode
and
it's easy to think that
learning happens only when you're
actively focused on something you're
trying really hard but it turns out a
lot of learning also happens when you're
relaxing because your brain continues to
work on it so
many students will think that a good
quality is to you know don't give up and
to persevere even if you re
actually in those type of situations
what you need is this diffused mode that
works when you are not focusing because
that can access information
in a whole different way it can help you
connect
ideas
so sometimes taking a break can can
really help you when while learning
um
and this is something you probably
noticed uh as well that you're
struggling with a problem in the evening
then you go to sleep and the next
morning you have a solution
it's because this diffused mode
keeps working on things in the
background and you can use this actually
more day-to-day if you're really
struggling with something you're
learning take a break or do something
else and then continue later
understanding these two modes for
example has helped me uh a lot
uh in my own learning
awesome that is great so so is that like
when uh is there is that part of the
explanation of why when i
um used to walk my dog sometimes it
would seem like you know i'm not paying
attention to anything but then all of a
sudden like when i would come back i
would seem to sit at my computer and
have lots more thoughts about the thing
that i was working on instead of exactly
because you might think that you're
relaxing you're taking a a break and and
you aren't and
and in a way you are but your brain
continues
to work with whatever you were doing
before that break
um another term for this in psychology
is the incubation effect that you know
sometimes you have a problem something
that needs to to incubate
a little bit and it's also what happens
if you if you struggle to recall the
name of a person you know you might see
someone on the stream and it's like oh i
know that person but you just can't
er
you just can't recall the name and then
all of a sudden half an hour later it
kind of falls down from the sky
it's that diffuse mode that's been
working in the background trying to find
uh the name within your your long-term
memory
got it got it
so that kind of relates to a question uh
that's just come in uh from kelden chen
on facebook that's asked how can we
balance our hobbies with our studies
and thinking about those two maybe it's
relating to those two modes but also
thinking about you know
as as we think about how much time
should we be studying and how much time
should we be maybe doing some other
things
oh that's a very good question and it
depends on many things of course but
what we do know is that if you are
learning a lot of new information
um
your or a part of your brain called
hippocampus can get overwhelmed if you
don't take breaks so you might think
that it's a good idea to sit for a very
long stretch of time but but your brain
struggles to process all of this
information and taking a few breaks
helps your brain
better store this information in
long-term memory so so breaks are
important for for learner for learning
also from that perspective
and
i i think you know how much time you
should spend learning it really depends
on
your ambitions and
how much time you you have have
how difficult the material is
but i've always felt that if you do
if you're a full-time college student
for example and you sit and work for
eight hours a day at a kind of normal
work day um you should be satisfied with
your
uh with your effort for that day and
there's actually research showing also
that students who study too much
actually do worse
because if you sit for too long of a
time you also tend to become more
ineffective and
and at some point it tips if you just
keep adding more and more hours
that makes sense that again it comes
back to those breaks and giving your
brain a chance to rest um that'll make
sense so it also relates we're heading
into summer
at least here in the this hemisphere
um and i know lots of parents are
thinking about you know how much
academic time
should they be spending this summer with
their with their kids and thinking about
you know worried that they didn't
achieve everything they wanted to at the
through the last school year because of
all the pandemic closures but as we
think about learning
outside of the classroom are there uh
particular tips and tricks when you
maybe don't have the the
whole structure of school around you but
things you can do to still keep learning
when it's maybe in a
less formal space
i
yes of course and there's there's tons
of things you can do what i would say
though is that and we talked a little
bit about this earlier that a lot of
learning is is hard work
especially when you're enrolled in
school and you have all this curriculum
and you have to go through it and you
only have this amount of time and
the most efficient way to to to to learn
it might be a little bit hard uh and so
i would say that you know also during
the summer it is important to
to to take a break and to recharge a bit
and to be ready for the new school year
um and i think it's it's it's healthy
and good if the kids you know at the end
of the summer miss school and want to
come back rather than
being exhausted but
learning doesn't
have to be uh boring or hard work either
there's a lot of learning that can
happen that is is fun and that is an
enjoyable activity and so i would say
you know especially during summer try to
find
things to learn to do that that the
students enjoy
and there's another added benefit to
this as well and that is that
especially if you let
curiosity be an important driver
so
you you choose yourself what you want to
to learn you follow your curiosity if
you do that you actually learn more
effectively as well because
getting your curiosity satisfied
um
leads to dopamine production in the
brain which strengthens memories in
long-term memory
so
curiosity can be a very strong
uh
strong driver for learning and letting
curiosity to lead you
is uh definitely recommended
i love that are there ways that parents
can help kind of nurture their kids
curiosity or you know help
help
urge them to ask those questions and to
be curious about the world
i think if you can expose kids to novel
things novel and environments uh kids
most kids already are quite curious
about things so so i mean there's lots
of things that you can do to stimulate
that and also ask
good questions
um
[Music]
so that you know instead of just going
through content or
you know for example if if if you are
discussing
the first world war and the second world
war and you can talk about you know you
might die straight straight into
something and say okay now we're going
to cover how
the second why the second world war came
about but if you instead try to lead up
with an interesting question for ex for
example that the world was most of
europe was in ruin and so many people
had died and countries were poor and so
many families have lost family members
uh why did
you know why did another major war break
out how could this happen when you were
just barely recovered from another major
war so you try to find an angle to it
where you can pose an interesting
question and then
that curiosity is awakened
uh it becomes more enjoyable and the
learning is better as well because once
you've got curiosity
um
information sticks better
yeah
and adding really also
go ahead
adding choice
uh
you know so
you might there might be certain things
that you cannot change so we we got to
spend more time on on on this and
that's just how it got to be but there's
a thousand ways that you could do that
so you could for example say oh you know
we should spend some time on this do you
want to do this do you want to watch
this documentary movie do you want to go
to that museum
and you know do you want to
us to read this book together
giving kids some choice um
is also a great way to
uh to boost motivation for for something
so this time well i think that some of
that might be some of the answer to this
question but um from facebook moniva
zeeshan asks oftentimes it's a big jump
for kids from elementary to middle
school and then middle school to high
school where there's lots of rigorous
homeworks and deadlines that kind of
make them lose some of that interest in
learning
maybe even some of that curiosity we've
been talking about
how can you work through that and what
would be your advice
yeah i mean this is a real challenge and
research all around the world shows that
the more years kids are in school the
less motivated they
become
so so you know the starting point isn't
isn't a great one but of course there
are many things that that you can do and
and research on motivation has come a
long way too for example um if you are
surrounded by other people who are
motivated for something some of that
motivation can transfer to you that's
called motivation contagion um in in
psychology
and so
uh
you know expressing some enthusiasm
yourself uh with your kids for what
you're learning or teachers should keep
this in mind too if they are really
excited about what they're teaching
they can actually increase the
motivation in their students as well so
that's one thing we already talked about
i'll just jump in and say that um sal
always says the best way to communicate
excitement about something is to
actually be excited yourself about it
yeah that totally makes sense
and i couldn't agree more and
neuroscience supports it so
uh i mean that's great we already talked
about choice perhaps you cannot decide
you know what we need to do but but you
can give uh but students cannot decide
what to do but you can give them choice
in how to do it
um and we also know that mastery is very
important for learning uh that that that
students feel that they actually learn
and they they progress
so being a little bit
paying a little bit attention to
students needs and making sure they get
the help
to to to master new things is also very
important
because if students have too many bad
experiences in a row they might lose
faith in themselves and their abilities
to learn and then
they don't uh
expand they don't um spend any effort
and and then of course they don't learn
and then it's just a vicious circle
right yeah i i talk a lot about in
motivation research there's this idea of
um if you think that you'll be
successful when you do something it's a
lot more likely that you'll try to do
that thing and if you think you're not
going to be successful if you think
you're going to fail you're not going to
be motivated to do that thing
um so it's expectancy of success which
of course kind of makes sense if you
just think about it who wants to do
something you think you're going to fail
at but if we can help kids feel like
they're going to be successful there's
something there
and there's a neural underpinning for
this as well because what gives you this
energy to expel effort you know to
pursue a task is dopamine and dopamine
is released in your brain it gives you
this just energy to act
but from an evolutionary perspective
it's not very efficient for us to be
spending times on things that we will
likely not be able to succeed with
so to protect our survival if you are
trying to catch
an eagle flying high up in the sky by
throwing rocks you'll probably soon see
that you cannot you know that's that's
not possible you cannot throw rocks that
high
and and so your brain will want you to
focus on something else give up on that
task and do something else that is
worthwhile so it will cut the dopamine
supply and you will lose interest in
pursuing that
and that's what happens when
in any type of activity if we feel that
if we no longer believe that we can
succeed
that dopamine
level
is quickly lowered in the brain and then
we lose the energy for it whereas if we
through either self-motivation or we
have someone around us that gives us a
little bit of help or believes in us
if we get instill that belief again that
we can do it dopamine production goes up
and we get that energy back and then we
actually succeed with it because we also
have the energy to uh
to pursue
fascinating
so we have a question about your book
from facebook manas levani says is learn
like a pro good for a fifth grader to
read if not what would you recommend for
young people to learn about how to learn
so for very young people i would
recommend my co-author's other book
learning how to learn
that book is especially written for kids
and and teens it has a very
simple and friendly language and lots of
fun
metaphors
uh
it's probably a book many kids can read
themselves but definitely a book they
can read together with their parents so
that would be my best bet for young
young learners
great
so it seems to me that a lot of these
things that we're talking about are
skills to practice the same way we
practice other kinds of skills like
learning how to you know ride your bike
or do those kinds of things is learning
to learn should we be
having our kids practice
learning behaviors in similar ways
yes we should and i mean there's good
evidence that some students are better
at picking up good
study techniques and good study habits
on the on their own they're
experimenting a little bit they're
reflecting about how they learn and
whereas other students might be stuck
with very ineffective ways to study
but that doesn't mean that they can't
improve because they can also learn
better techniques but they need to need
a little bit of extra help
and and so learning as a skill is is
important as as well and should be honed
and sort of throughout life not only in
during early years but you know learning
challenges and context keeps changing
throughout our lives but one of the
things that what can help you in any
learning situation is being
metacognitive which is a very fancy word
for thinking about how you are thinking
and that's and and i mean research shows
that some people does this more
naturally they take a step back and they
you know look at how they're learning
and they're asking themselves whether
they are
doing
working in a smart way or whether they
should change something but this is also
something you can practice you know with
your kids if you're learning together
and and
you can ask your kids questions about
how they've been learning that forces
them to reflect for example
you know
how are we going to learn this and what
what do you suggest why do you want to
learn in that way and after you've had a
session you know you can ask how did you
think that this went
is there something you would have done
differently next time
so often in education we're very good at
asking questions and
about the content
but
we should spend a little bit more time
about the process of learning as well
how we are learning and reflecting and
thinking
about that too
that definitely makes sense and that
that process of um
how did it go
it strikes me there's some
potentially goal setting that is maybe
helpful there too about
at the beginning what do you want to
learn so that at the end you can say did
we get there and when where that is is
is
like that kind of goal setting and
reflection uh helpful based on the
research that you've seen
yeah that's that's normally part of it
so in the beginning you
you know you set a goal and you also try
to understand what the success criteria
is or what what you
sort of what what you need to learn and
then you try to then you select some
tools or some strategies
and which techniques you should use
depend completely on the learning
challenge itself one technique might be
great for something but not work for
something else and that's also why it's
important to think of learning
techniques as a kind of toolkit a mental
toolkit that you keep developing
so that you have you have strong tools
but but also the knowledge about when to
apply them
and then typically at the end you will
look back and you will see whether uh
when you reach your goal and whether
um you selected the appropriate tool or
whether you would want to do something
different another time
that makes sense so that seems like a
good note to leave us on a mental tool
kit that you develop throughout your
life
i like it thank you so much for joining
us today uh
just brush the surface 30 minutes always
goes by so fast but for people who were
interested
pick up the book learning like a pro out
learn learn like a pro out today um
we're actually going to have uh dr
oakley on on june 15th she also has a
book aimed particularly teachers that is
also interesting that we're going to
talk to her about so stay tuned for that
and we will see you next time thank you
for joining us
you